[Music]
my name is Jason I'm a product manager
on Google cloud my colleague Michael is
going to come up on stage a little bit
later and show you a demo so this is
what's new in servers compute it's where
we take you through all the things I've
been working on since last cloud next
and some of the things that are coming
up soon we have quite a lot of content
to get through we'll do our best to get
through it all if there's any questions
at the end and we have time there's some
microphones here in the middle if we run
out of time we'll be loitering outside
the room afterwards if you want to grab
us for a quick question and don't forget
to rate the session at the end in the
app that'll be great okay
so let's get into it service on Google
cloud is the way we think about it is
more than just compute we have a view
that service covers a full range of
services the rationale here is that if
you want to build your application and
you have an objective to not touch a
server and not manage infrastructure you
need to do that across more than just
compute
however for today we're going to focus
just on that compute portion and so
there are many other sessions that will
cover the other things today it's just
compute mostly we do have a few things
that perhaps deviate from that but
mostly Wisco to compute as far as
compute goes on cloud platform there's
two products that create our compute
suite today App Engine and cloud
functions many of you will probably
already know these products App Engine
is our platform for building web
applications and cloud functions is our
event-driven functions as a service
offering for those perhaps unfamiliar
with App Engine quick recap source based
developer experience so you write your
application in your language of choice
and you deploy source code
to the environment it's great for
running your traditional web app with
your web framework of choice express
various Python flasks Java spring etc
and it also comes with a range of
features that necessary for modern web
applications like versioning traffic
splitting out-of-the-box TLS encryption
custom domains etc many the of the
runtimes the that we support this week
are now generally available GA so PHP 7
to go on 11 and no 10 those runtimes
that are all GA we have some new
versions of runtimes coming up Java 11
is currently in alpha and the
long-awaited Ruby 2.5 now available on
App Engine there are some other sessions
going on this week if you want to know
more about Ruby's particularly there's a
session tomorrow and a general App
Engine session also tomorrow if you're
interested okay
cloud functions is as I mentioned our
event-driven functions as a service
offering again for those unfamiliar you
deploy a function it reacts to an event
and you can call other api's and it's
really the sort of the glue code
solution in cloud platform along the
same vein we have new runtimes G a
Python 37 no date go 111 and newly
announced this week on cloud functions
is no 10 in beta and go 112 in alpha and
finally Java is coming to cloud
functions Java 8 in alpha this week and
there's another session you can go and
look at to learn more about Java on
cloud platform a service Java developers
journey tomorrow so that they'll tell
you more about how we do Java in GCP on
service
okay some new features that we talked
about or we alluded to last year on
cloud functions and we'll go into a
little bit more detail now so max
instances last year we refer to this as
scaling controls what this allows you to
do is set a maximum number of instances
of your cloud function so it sets an
upper bound a number of instances you
configure this at deployment time and
it's really useful for situations where
you have perhaps a back-end system that
has a limited capacity so I'll just take
you through how that works the little
cloud is the internet so a request comes
in to our front end and we'll route that
request to an instance of your cloud
function so far so good
as more requests come in more instances
of your cloud function will be created
assuming that the current ones are busy
to serve those requests what max
instances allows you to do is specify an
upper bound to that so you'll tell us in
this in this case max instances are four
we won't create more than four instances
subsequent requests that come in will be
queued but this is important because
you're you may have a spike in traffic
that hits the boundary of your max
instances but it may only be temporary
and you don't want to necessarily
immediately reject that request
so the queuing gives sort of a smoothing
effect to this spiking us in the traffic
eventually of course if the system is
too overloaded meaning that the the
requests in the front end are too many
for this max instances to deal with then
at some point that that will be rejected
but no matter what if you have your
downstream system that has a maximum
capacity for example a database with the
maximum number of connections then the
max instances will ensure that you're
not overloading your underlying data set
overloading the underlying database will
cause problems with all serving
functions potentially so that's max
instances that's available now another
feature that it's also long awaited is
serverless VPC access so this allows you
to connect both cloud functions and app
engine to your V PC let's talk about
what that looks like
so a V PC today it's it's available in
in cloud platform allows you to create a
network boundary around more than two
potentially but in this case two regions
so you have a shared network address
space with the service V PC access via a
connector you're able to send traffic
from your cloud function into the V PC
so if you have resources in your V PC
already maybe you have services on a
virtual machine or you're hosting a
Redis cluster whatever it is you can now
access that through cloud functions and
App Engine additionally if you have
on-premises networks connected to the
cloud via VPN that are then connected
into the V PC you can route traffic all
the way from your cloud function through
the V PC back to your on-premises
infrastructure so as I mentioned great
for accessing services running on GCE
gke if you're running a third party
solution hosted on a VM some Google
services are run in this network for
example cloud memory store and any
services running in your own datacenter
okay rolling through the features I told
you a lot to get through per function
identity but this allows you to do I'll
skip this slide and go to the more
interesting one with the nice picture of
the cat so let's say you had a a
function that was reading from a cloud
storage bucket and you have a developer
that is wanting to deploy this function
that reads from a cloud storage bucket
the function has an identity it has a
service account in the in the Google
cloud vernacular that identity has some
role associated with it and so in order
for that function to read from the
storage bucket the role needs to have
the appropriate permissions needs to be
able to have the authority to read from
that storage bucket now your developer
may have a different role he might be a
developer but as a result of needing
access to the function that needs access
to the storage bucket by extension this
developer implicitly needs the same role
otherwise there's a possibility of a
privilege escalation so this is fine
this is this is great this works let's
say you have another function that wants
to read from a different bucket well
previously both those functions would
have the same identity if they had the
same identity that identity has the same
permissions which means that this other
bucket needs this other storage bucket
needs the same permissions as the first
one well there's a sort of an implied
level of access here that you may not
want you may not have intended for your
developer to access this other bucket
but you didn't really have a way to opt
out of that because both functions
shared the same identity what we really
really want to do is swap that identity
with a different identity that has a
different role and a different set of
permissions give the bucket the
appropriate level of access and this
means that this developer can no longer
access this bucket so it really gives a
narrowing effect in a more fine-grained
control over access control
/ function basis functions today can be
deployed in these four regions - in the
u.s. one in Europe one in Asia this week
we are making available two additional
regions one in London and one in Hong
Kong okay switch gears a little bit I
mentioned we're talking about service
compute mostly this is part of the
mostly category cloud tasks for anyone
who's used App Engine in the past there
is a feature of App Engine called task
queues which is very very popular
feature asynchronous queuing product
unfortunately only available if you're
using App Engine well cloud tasks is the
first-class GCP product that does a very
similar thing its GAE this week so let
me just take you through the canonical
use case for cloud tasks in the context
of service something like cloud
functions so imagine you had written a
function that does three things whatever
those things may be the second part of
that let's say was a heavyweight
operation maybe it was transforming an
image or doing some sort of heavyweight
task that you realize that doesn't need
to be synchronous it doesn't need to be
in the request flow it can happen at a
later time
now perhaps traditionally you might have
spawned a thread to process this
asynchronous job and returned quickly to
the client to the to the requester well
threads have this side effect that
they're perhaps not durable if your
process fails completely what happens to
that asynchronous work the alternative
is that you can use cloud tasks so you
in queue a task it will happen in the
background asynchronously and then you
return quickly to the caller
some of the features additional features
which I'm going to talk about in a
second it has a configurable retry
policy again with the sort of the
traditional way of perhaps spawning a
thread if that process that you spawn
the thread too
to execute fail for some reason there's
there's not necessarily a durability and
a retry policy that you can apply to
that
so cloud task salary allows you to do
that this rate limiting dynamic
scheduling this is really cool you can
say execute this thing but do it in one
hour from now you can target the output
so in this case I'm not really concerned
about in this case on screen I'm not
really concerned about what happens
after but you can you can target
arbitrary HTTP endpoints and you can add
authentication I'll talk about that in a
little bit that's also new this week
it's a little bit more about rate
limiting and retry in cloud tasks so
similar to the situation we I described
before with max instances where you have
a back-end system that has some sort of
capacity limit you can use max instances
to control the flow of traffic into that
back-end but sometimes it's hard to
determine how many instances you need if
your back-end system is let's say an API
that has literally a rate limit you can
only call this API n times every M
minutes how many instances do I need to
make sure I don't exceed that right well
it depends right it depends on how
quickly you're able to call the API well
with a retry policy oh sorry with rate
limiting in cloud tasks let's say you
had this situation where you exceeded
the limit of off the backend so what you
could do is put a queue in front of it
using cloud tasks with a rate limit so
let's walk through this you have a bunch
of requests coming in to cloud functions
those cloud functions are in killing
tasks on to a queue the queue itself has
a rate limit so no matter what the
backend system is not going to be
overloaded and so you just have that
rate limit match whatever the capacity
of your back-end
is if whatever reason some request fails
on that back-end you can configure a
retry policy so that there's an element
of durability and reliability to it
and there's another session on Thursday
to talk that talks more about
asynchronous tasks using cloud tasks
cloud scheduler is everyone keeping up
I'm not gonna say very much about this
it's great because it's simple it's a
managed cron service so you can schedule
repeating executions you can also have a
retry policy if your execution failed
you can have arbitrary HTTP so you could
use cloud scheduler and cloud tasks to
trigger something off cloud platform
just anything that's available over on
an HTTP endpoint and it also includes
this authentication which I'm going to
talk about in a moment and there's
another session there again on Thursday
that involves users cloud scheduler
extensively okay so I mentioned in a
couple of scenarios this idea of cloud
scheduler and cloud tasks in meeting or
calling services via HTTP this has
perhaps a problem where the service
that's receiving this call from cloud
tasks of card schedule it needs to
validate and authenticate the person
calling them if you set up stand up a
web server to be called on a schedule
how do you know that it's Google cloud
scheduler calling you how do you verify
that identity and more importantly if it
was just well I can verify that it's
Google cloud that's great but how do I
know it's my Google cloud how do I know
it's my project and not some other
Google cloud project calling me so let's
say you're executing your cloud function
or you're executing something some
arbitrary HTTP endpoint that's out there
on the internet well you can associate
in the same way you associate an
identity to a cloud function that we
described earlier you can associate an
identity to the resource that is sending
you these
sending you these requests so your your
cloud scheduler job or your cloud task
skew will have an identity at the time
the HTTP request is sent we will put an
open ID connect JWT token in the HTTP
header that corresponds to that identity
it's a token that expires but when you
receive that token you can validate that
using standard open protocols to
validate the authenticity of the claims
made in that token I mentioned cloud
tasks and cloud scheduler this
capability is also available as of today
in pops up so cloud pub/sub also allows
you to push and it has a push
subscription allows you to push messages
to HTTP now you can attach an identity
to your subscription in cloud pops up
when it pushes the HTTP request the
message it will carry with it a bearer
token an open ID Connect JWT token ok so
that's all the things that we've been
working on in the last 12 months in
terms of cloud functions App Engine
cloud tasks cloud scheduler but this is
cloud next so what are we doing next
many of you may have already seen some
of this but here we go
so traditionally service has a couple of
these characteristics it's typically
source driven you write your code
function or app whatever it might be
obviously it's service so I don't want
any operational overhead so it's no ops
and it has a characteristic that you
typically pay only when when you're
using it scales to zero but some things
can be constraining so adding custom
libraries or native binaries can
sometimes be cumbersome arbitrary
runtimes you know we talked about the
runtime support expanding on App Engine
and cloud functions but what if I want
to run Erlang or rust well you're sort
of requiring the platform provide
to do that and to do a lot of work
before you can get that well there's
another solution that people have been
using for this and it's containers and
so the container is sort of the lingua
franca of portability of code
so it's obviously container driven
unfortunately most container platforms
do have at least some amount of ops
you're creating a cluster you're
managing a cluster of containers and the
billing model is typically you pay for
the instances of the machines that are
run in your containers but it has these
advantages where you can specify
arbitrary libraries you can specify
arbitrary runtimes it operates in a very
similar way to a virtual machine so what
we're announcing this week is a new
product in GCP called cloud run which
brings those two worlds together
so you get all the benefits of a
container being able to run an arbitrary
runtime arbitrary custom libraries you
specify whatever you want in that
container but we give you all the
operational model of a service product
so you have no ops you only pay when
it's being used so going to talk a
little bit about this there's three
aspects that we identify with cloud run
one is container for production in
seconds you know this was a really hard
work for us it's one thing to say well
you can run a container but if you have
to jump through 20 hoops to get there
then it's not really service there's no
rule book that says service has to be
easy but we all know that that's how we
want it to be so you I should be able to
give Google a docker image and Curly URL
in a few seconds
it's natively service what does that
mean well if you go on to the cloud
console and you create a cloud run
service it will be serviced by default
it will be no ups you pay anyone fort
use scales up fast
scales to 0 etc and the last point is
it's one developer experience wherever
you want to go I'll talk
about this a little bit later but we
also have a version of cloud run that
runs on your GE cluster so if you're
already a GE customer or you already
have main investment in kubernetes and
that's where you want to run the bulk of
your workload
you may have developers internally that
want some of the agility and benefits of
the serverless developer experience
where I just have to deploy and I get
something back in seconds well you can
run that same capability on your GE
cluster and some of you may have
encountered this term Co native I'll
talk a little bit more about that as
well
so cloud run is Google clouds
implementation of the Kay native serving
specifications I'm going to I'll pause
that and leave it there I'll come back
to it later it's very simple it looks
like this if you literally take a photo
of that OCR and type into a console it
will work but rather than do that let me
show you
okay this is cloud console I'm logged
into the cloud run section so here on
the Left nav we have a new a new option
called cloud run over here I just have a
cloud shell I'm not gonna do anything
fancy I just wanted to show you how easy
it is to create and deploy a new service
as a container using cloud run so I have
a very simple nodejs application in fact
I'm so lazy
I literally copied it from the hello
world example on Express jeaious
the only thing I changed is this port
variable better than that it's identical
I have a package.json
for those familiar with node will know
what that means for those not it's the
canonical deployment descriptor for
nodejs
the only thing I changed here is this
start command here and so if I just run
I have to specify my port if I just run
that regular old NPM nothing fancy going
on and I preview that in the browser
there we go hello cloud next let's just
quickly change that to prove that it's
real okay I don't know if I have to
restart but let's do it anyway refresh
ok so that's real so I have an index J
as a package of JSON the only other file
I have here is a docker file and this is
a pretty lightweight
it's just inheriting from the default
official nodejs 10 image it runs an NPM
install
and then it calls NPM start the same
command I just called in the console
well I have a docker file but cloud run
takes docker images so how do i turn my
docker file into a document I could run
docker build locally and that would
produce an image and upload it to a
repository and that would work but we
have a service actually that will do
this for me he's my cheat sheet so I'm
going to use a product that we have in
cloud called cloud build that
surprise-surprise
builds docker images so live demo let's
see if it works
of course it's going to work I have a
cloud build over here let's refresh that
there it is you can see I did a few
earlier takes about 20 or 30 seconds
okay it's still building and it's done
there it is okay so that has given me
this image down here so this is a docker
image in the repository that has my
node.js app so all I need to do now is
going to cloud run I'm going to create a
service first thing it's going to ask
this for my container image URL that I
just created
it's picked up the name by default
location is fine I'm gonna check this
box what this is saying is let me let me
hit the URL without any authentication
now by default it's off you need to
authenticate yourself against your own
service just with your Google Cloud
account for the purpose of this demo I'm
going to make it public so that I can so
I can hit it without without having to
do any of that and I just go create so
what this is going to do is so I already
built my docker image it's uploaded to
the repository this is going to pull
down that image set up all the routing
and configuration necessary and make my
service available and you see it gave me
a URL it generated a TLS certificate for
me I click that URL
there's my service
there's something else I just give you a
little sneak peek at that I'll come back
to later okay avert your eyes it's yeah
more I wanted to just point out that the
first line this is the llamo file
description of the service that I just
created
it's a que native compatible service now
for those that aren't familiar with what
Co native means that it's not going to
mean a lot to you right now
I do have some slides later on all that
will start to make more sense okay back
to slides can we switch back to the
slides
pretty please okay that was how I will
so what do you get
well when you deploy a cloud run service
you get HTTP you can also add we didn't
demonstrate this but you can also add a
custom domain so within a few minutes
you can start your container based web
application add your custom domain and
you're off to the races
the allow authentication on or off tick
box that I mentioned before well we
talked about the identity based
authentication for cloud toss cloud
scheduler and pub/sub well we will
automatically validate that token for
you so if you if you leave that tick box
on ticked and then you in queue a task
into task queues let's say that's
pushing via HTTP to your cloud run
service well it will handle all that
authentication for you so the cloud run
service is not in vocable from the
outside world but it is invoked will by
you either directly if you authenticate
yourself or asynchronously by one of
these services so HTTP plus the Open ID
Connect JWT
a sand it's automatically validated as I
mentioned okay I want to sidebar just
quickly to talk about concurrency when
we use the term instance that's what we
use to describe an instantiation of your
function app or container in this case
it's typically where you nominate
resources like memory and CPU
importantly it has a life cycle that
might be beyond your request so it will
create an instance you send a request to
it we serve the request that doesn't
mean we instantly kill the instance
because of course another request might
be coming and we want to save that cold
start time so an instance has its own
life cycle and then concurrency the way
we refer to it is the number of requests
processed at the same time on a single
instance so it looks like this request
comes in same diagrams before hits the
front end and a served by instances now
in the case of a product like cloud
functions concurrency is one and you
can't change it one function will deal
with one request at one time and that's
great because it means the programming
model is very simple the billing model
is very simple while your request is
running you're paying the end but
there's a problem well your function may
not be using all the resources on that
instance all the time and CPU is the lot
is the biggest culprit here you're not
you're unlikely to be CPU bound for the
entire duration of your function you're
gonna be i/o bound you're gonna be doing
other things network bound in some way
so zooming in on this in this scenario
it might be better if we could utilize
more of the machine during the request
if we could move some of that CPU
utilization into the gaps of another
instance and we would do this by
changing concurrency but why is this new
we've been doing this forever on virtual
machines well it's not new but it's new
for service and particularly it's new
for services because the service billing
model has traditionally been you pay for
the lifetime of request well what is the
lifetime of a request if there are more
than one
how do we how do we make concurrency
service well here's a way of describing
it here's my instance the instance has a
lifecycle as I mentioned that may may be
beyond the lifecycle of your request
request starts and ends over a period of
time and in the traditional model that's
what you would pay for you would pay
while that request is being served well
what happens when another request comes
in offset to that first one starts
second one starts first one in second
one ends well it's pretty simple we just
extend it to the boundary so the
billable time now becomes the time where
at least one concurrent request is being
served so why do we want to do
concurrency why do we want to complicate
complicate our lives well there's a
couple of really important benefits one
is you have fewer cold starts imagine a
ramp up in QPS if every instance of your
function or application can only deal
with one request at the same time every
subsequent request that comes in at
approximately the same time needs to
spawn a new instance a spawning a new
instance creates a cold start well if
you can serve some of those requests on
an existing instance you have
necessarily fewer cold starts you
therefore have a faster ramp up if you
have a spike in traffic and importantly
you have better utilization so the
underlying machinery is going to be
better utilized which has both speed
efficiency and cost implications the one
caveat is that you give away some of the
simplicity in the programming model if
you're storing state in global scope
outside of your function for example or
outside of your app we have to be aware
that there may be more than one request
concurrently accessing that global State
so maybe not don't do that and you you
you do open yourself up to more race
conditions if things are competing so I
want to invite my colleague Michael onto
the stage he's going to do a much better
demo than mine that will show some of
these benefits
thanks Jason I'm Jason to you switch
yeah
so I'm excited to be talking about some
of the work we've been doing in cloud
one to achieve fast scaling so why is
fast scaling important well for server
lists workloads we tend to have bursty
request stream and so for this for these
bursts we want to be able to quickly
react and handle all the requests with
low latency and of course we don't want
to be paying for instances when we're
not using them and so we want to scale
down and that's me as Jason mentioned if
we have too many instances and we have a
lot of cold starts and then we have the
higher latency associated with that so
the trade-off for the balance we're
trying to strike here is to create lots
of instances on demand as needed but not
to create too many so that both cold
start Dayton sees and the the bill is
appropriate for that workload and so
what I'm gonna be demoing here is um
it's kind of the fast scaling that we
have for cloud one that's an order of
magnitude faster than what we've had in
our existing server list products like
App Engine and GCF and so I mean here's
a monitor of how many instances we have
right now I'm going to deploy an
existing image that I've already built
and then the workload is gonna be pretty
simple I'm going to use Apache bench to
send 10,000 concurrent requests each one
of these requests are just burning CPU
and executing for one second so given
that I set max concurrency equal one in
this deployment and I have 10,000
requests I expect concurrent clients
rather expect around 10,000 clients on
the order and I'll explain why later
it's a bit higher so then we start a
workload now there's some lag in this
monitoring and then you see the number
of instances start up and it's just it's
a matter of seconds we're going to see
around 10,000 instances start up and so
this is pretty cool
and you're going to see that the number
of instances slightly overshoots or
above 10,000 and the reason we do that
is and we need to be able to handle any
spike of workloads that's higher than
the then like if we're gonna get an
exist more requests we want to be able
to handle that and we also want to not
have the instances have too high of
utilization oops okay so the test is now
done yep so request test is done and so
so that's okay I loaded quickly was it
started 10,000 instances you can see
here in a matter of seconds and in less
than 10 seconds I started or 8,000
instances here and so that for my next
demo when I want to show is what Jason
refer to earlier in terms of concurrency
most requests aren't spending all the
time burning CPU they may be doing
requests to kind of say cloud machine
learning or Google Cloud storage and so
we can have concurrent requests at the
same time and so when I deploy I can get
to say how many concurrent requests I
want and in this case I'm gonna say I
want five requests and now I'm deploying
a new version and instances are not
shared between revisions even if the
same service and so the I'm gonna have
cold start for the egg for the new
workload that I want now okay and so
here we go there's your instances right
now
it's pretty old-school and when I run a
factory bench on five different machines
starting ten thousand concurrent
requests on each one of them and then as
was a previous desk you expect see kind
of a rapid scale up to an order of
10,000 instances but unlike the previous
test we're now having multiple requests
per instance and so we're getting in the
order of 50,000 requests for a second
this test runs for around a minute and a
half so these have pretty impressive
numbers but why do we need this kind of
rapid scaling I want to give you a few
examples of customers use cases that
we've had on App Engine and GCF Google
cloud functions and so on App Engine a
New York Times hosts a crossword puzzle
so every day when the crossword puzzle
is released there's a significant ramp
up in terms of customer of clients
trying to get the crossword and because
in App Engine we didn't scale this fast
the New York Times tends to ramp up
manually instances to handle that load
what was this rapid scaling customers
don't have to think about that they
don't have to predict how much load is
coming in the system will very quickly
scale up to a necessary number of
instances another example is snap runs
most of the compute workload on App
Engine and they do very rapid deployment
so you want to do deployments of new
code every few minutes and when you have
millions of queries per second to a
large service like snap you want to be
able to handle kind of migrated from the
old version to the new version really
quickly and so this kind of rapid
scaling allows us to spin up a lot of
the new containers for the new version
and migrate traffic quickly to the new
version now you'll see here the D as of
the client requests one down where most
we're down to 280 instances but you're
not paying for that so you quickly spun
them down but you're only paying for the
instances are running your workload and
so these instances are available
because we leave the garbage collect
them in case we want to get more
requests and so I just want to add that
we have a shared infrastructure for App
Engine Google Cloud function and in
cloud 1 and we're going to be enabling
this in cloud and Google Cloud functions
as well app engine's billing model makes
it difficult to support this because
there's a minimum of 15 minute billing
for the instance so we're only going to
enable this in cloud one and Google
cloud functions and then finally just a
couple of caveats we by default we are
limiting every cloud 1 service to 1,000
instances but if you need more let us
know and we'll increase our limit
something like 10,000 if you need and
we're just limited by our data center
capacity and the other caveat is we're
kind of this fast scaling is brand-new
we're still finally tuning it and so
it's it's not enabled for all projects
yet but we're gonna be enabling it
shortly for every project so I gave a
few examples of kind of customer use
cases for this kind of rapid scaling and
we want to put this out there and see
how you use it and we're excited to see
how you use this capability thank you
okay I just want to reflect a moment on
what we just saw
we Michael sent some load to a service
that went from zero to 10,000 instances
in a matter of seconds it really is
incredible and my colleagues back at the
office told me to say it's over 9000 I
didn't really know what that meant
okay so just in summary serverless
compute on google cloud cloud functions
App Engine and now the new Service Cloud
run is a great session if you want to
know more about cloud run which is today
actually this afternoon container once
serviced everywhere anyway rather okay I
circling back to the start I mentioned
this thing called K native for those
unfamiliar Canadia is an open source
community developed platform that allows
you to build deploy and manage modern
service workloads it all starts with
kubernetes and sto we've defined these
three categories of components there's a
native build can--it of serving Canadian
ting cloud run that you've seen is the
middle component it's the serving part
of the co native specification and above
all of that there's a declarative API
service we use that term declarative
it's a kubernetes style API service I
showed you the amyl file before of the
cloud run service that is the
declaration of that service that you
would send to ke native to instantiate
or to provision the resources necessary
for that resource in your creative
cluster or service if it's in the case
of cloud run it's been community
developed we've been working closely
with folks like pivotal IBM s ap Red Hat
etc to design a server list developer
experience in a service platform that
meets the needs of customers
as I mentioned it's based on kubernetes
and sto cloud run is our instantiation
of K native cloud run is the fully
service fully managed pay for what you
use you can also run cloud run on gke
and they are both compatible with K
native so I haven't gone very deep on
the K native side I'd encourage you to
to look more into it there's a session
that covers how to use co native in
hybrid use cases that is on Thursday if
you want to know more about Canada if
I'd encourage you to get all into that
so that's the end we made it don't
forget to rate and I think we probably
don't have time for a lot of questions
so Michael and I will make ourselves
available outside the room immediately
after this session and if you want to
know more these are the canonical
locations for our run and for service on
GCP
[Applause]
[Music]